hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well John Stuart Mill
begins his work on Liberty by specifying
that he's not going to be discussing the
liberty or freedom of the will which is
a metaphysical doctrine but rather
something that falls within the domain
of social and political philosophy what
he's calling civil or social Liberty the
Liberty or freedom of an individual
within a society to do certain things do
being understood in a very broad sense
and a little ways in he's going to
clarify what he means by talking about
the different types and areas of Liberty
so he talks first about there being a
sphere of action in which society as
distinguished from the individual has if
any only an indirect interest so what
does that mean having an indirect
interest society itself is not acting
it's the individuals who are involved
who are doing things and society does
not have a direct interest as it would
be say for example in compelling
somebody to give testimony in a law case
or keeping people from burning their
neighbor's houses down it has only an
indirect interest
that is perhaps it could affect others
within society or perhaps it might not
so he says that comprehending all of
that portion of a person's life and
conduct which effects only him or
herself or if it affects others because
it could affect other people only with
their free voluntary and undeceived
consent and participation and he
clarifies he says when I say only
himself
I mean directly and in the first
instance for whatever effect oneself may
affect others through oneself you know
if I take drugs for example and it
affects my mood and then I don't follow
through on commitments that I've made to
others we could say that they are
indirectly affected by that but they're
not directly affected by it by state
getting high from the drugs so he says
this is the appropriate region of human
liberty all of this sphere of action
then he goes and he breaks it down into
three different domains which are going
to be discussed through the rest of the
work in considerable detail there is the
inward domain of consciousness we could
call this you know freedom of thought or
however you want to frame it
then there's the entire domain of what
we can call today lifestyle and then
finally what he calls combination of
individuals so we should look at each of
these in turn he says the first domain
is the inward domain of consciousness
which demands liberty of conscience in
the he says most comprehensive sense so
what is Liberty of conscience Liberty of
conscience is not just the you know
having a conscience and being able to
listen to that you know however we
conceive of it's still small voice or
the angel on the shoulder whatever
imaginary thing that you have for
construing what conscience is
traditionally understood conscience is a
sort of you know the self telling itself
this is right this is wrong it could be
properly formed so it actually gives
the answers it could be improperly
formed but the idea is that it's better
for us to listen to whatever those those
you know practical reasoning resources
we have inside then not to do so and
then you know discussion of this goes
all the way back quite a ways into
philosophy and so liberty of conscience
in the you know broadest extent is
important and then he says freedom of
opinion and freedom of here's Liberty of
thought and feeling absolute freedom of
opinion and sentiment on all subjects
practical or speculative scientific
moral or theological so let's think
about this he uses the terms thought and
then opinion so the things that we we
actually think we should be free and the
things that we actually do think and we
should be free and the thinking that we
do with them the thought processes that
we have the formation of our opinions if
we want to read garbage books and you
know watch true crime TV and get the
idea because of that that the world is
much more dangerous than it is Mill says
that you know unless it's actually
affecting other people we should be
allowed to have that freedom to think
crazy thoughts about you know how likely
it is that somebody's going to break
into our house and destroy everything or
rape us or kill us and ignore the things
that are much more likely to injure us
like say car crashes now sentiment
sentiments and feeling this is where
Mill is saying that we should be allowed
freedom provided it's not affecting
other people in a direct way against
their interests that we should be free
to feel how we want to feel so you know
let's take a very silly example if I
don't like broccoli and you do I mean
more likely that's the opposite of the
case because I actually do like broccoli
and many people don't
then you shouldn't compel me to somehow
like broccoli
shouldn't bring coercive power to bear
on me so that I have to deny my own
sentiments about that and when we get to
other things other feelings mill is
saying we should have freedom and he
says on all subjects all subjects
practical the day to day things how we
ought to behave and speculative whether
the moon actually is real or not
you know conspiracy theories about moon
landings and things like that
Mills saying we should have freedom of
opinion and sentiment on those matters
scientific moral theological all of
those sorts of things
then he says that in this inward domain
of consciousness we also should include
liberty of something that seems to go
outside of that domain and get into the
rest of the world he says that the
liberty of expressing and publishing
opinions may seem to fall under a
different principle why would it fall
under a different principle because it
seems to be external but according to
mill he says being almost as much
importance as the liberty of thought
itself and resting in great part on the
same reasons it is practically
inseparable from it so our freedom of
expression which is really the thing
that I think people go to this book for
the most falls within this first domain
of freedom of thought and feeling going
along with the freedom of being able to
think and feel goes the freedom to
express our thoughts and feelings and
even publish them
the second big domain that he's going to
talk about which he treats in a separate
chapter is that of what we nowadays call
lifestyle
he says secondly the principle what is
the heart of the principle here the harm
principle requires liberty of tastes and
pursuits of framing the plan of our life
to suit our own character of doing as we
like
subject to such consequences as may
follow without impediment from our
fellow creatures so long as what we do
does not harm them even though they
should think our conduct foolish
perverse or wrong so if I want to spend
my available money and let's say there's
not you know very much of it just enough
basically to you know cover rent and
insurance and food and you know save up
a little bit for medical rainy days and
things like that if I want to use the
spare income that I have for you know
buying video games or giving it to the
poor or giving it to somebody who's much
richer than I am in a rather you know
sort of perverse line of reasoning all
of that is perfectly fine as far as mill
is concerned and nobody should be
impinging upon that if I'm into you know
metal and I say well I'm only going to
listen to stuff from the 1970s and 80s
with rare exceptions and somebody else
comes along and says oh but the really
wonderful stuff has been happening from
2000 on you must listen to that I'm
perfectly fine according to mill and
saying no I choose not to and you can't
compel me to do that if I if I want to
appreciate you know cereal boxes instead
of fine art that's perfectly fine as
well it's up to me to form my own tastes
and pursue the course of life that I
want to do you know again we could look
at instances where it starts to bleed
over into other matters if I wanna you
know take baths every single day and a
shower in the morning and scrub my hands
you know for two minutes every time that
I do anything in the bathroom whether
it's going to the bathroom or brushing
my teeth or even walking in the door and
checking how my hair looks there's
something like that that's up to me so
long as I'm not actually affecting other
people like using too much water
something like that you know in an
unjust way if I don't want to bathe at
all well you know until that becomes an
to a problem for other people that's
within the scope of this this second
domain so you know what we have has
hobbies or fandom or allegiances what
sports we watch or don't watch all of
that falls under this domain of
lifestyles whether we're consumerist s--
or anti-consumerist anything along those
sorts of lines the third thing he says
is that there's also a Liberty within
the same limits of combination among
individuals getting together with others
into associations into groups into
organizations joining organizations that
already exist founding new ones he calls
this the freedom to unite for any
purpose not involving harm to others the
persons combining being supposed to be a
full age and not forced or deceived so
this you know we we probably would have
to exclude some things from that
for example many multi-level marketing
you know associations that people would
join where they're not quite sure what
they're getting into and it's been sold
to them in a deceptive way okay that
would not fall under this but getting
together with a bunch of friends to play
Pinochle on Sunday nights and taking a
collection so that you can have chips
and beer and I don't know watch I got
true crime shows on TV or something like
that perfectly fine and nobody should
interfere with that provided your
association is not interfering with
other people you know if you're gonna
insist on doing your pinochle games in I
don't know say the the city hall after
the city hall is closed or a public
library they would be perfectly you know
fine and saying no no no you can't break
in and do that but you know if you're
doing it in your own home or some other
establishment and you're not you know
actually disturbing in any major way
other people you're not transgressing
their rights that would be perfectly
so we have here a pretty extensive
conception of what the domains of
Liberty would be there's you know the
sphere of action in which society has
only an indirect interest and the book
is really structured along the lines of
considering each of these in turn
you